you're good okay you're good yeah you're
rolling your red lights on okay here we
go
as this is Hamburg registry for sure I
get great joy preserving the American
hamburger head mayor okay that wasn't
convincing enough my name is George Motz
and it is my job to preserve hamburger
history which you may or may not know is
that there are many many regional Styles
out there and today I'm gonna show you a
really cool one it's called the slug
burger you may or may not know that [ __ ]
almost got it
sorry I'm sorry yeah mom's my 15 year
old daughter who's also camera op number
two number one ads no the camera let's
do it like most regional burgers in
America the slug burger exists in a very
very tiny part of the country
specifically in northern Mississippi
hard times leading up to the Great
Depression men people had to use
inventive ways to extend their food
supply when it came to a hamburger
restaurant that meant taking yesterday's
bread
stale bread crushing it up and putting
it into today's beef supply thereby
extending the beef supply it was a very
ingenious way to make the meat last for
many many days 1900 of history let's
cook beef and we have breadcrumbs you
take it like a hero roll and you dry it
out overnight and then you throw it in
your Cuisinart a blender you want big
chunks in there big chunks are very
important how much breadcrumbs you put
in is up to you
adding breadcrumbs okay so there are no
slugs in this burger in case your hope
maybe you're hoping for slugs the name
actually comes from the old term for a
nickel because these burgers is to cost
a nickel they would say give me a slug
maybe some people like slugs in their
burger
so all I'm doing is combining the meat
and the breadcrumbs that's it don't put
anything else in here no seasoning
nothing I have a ball of beef
it's breadcrumbs it's high heat it's
beef it's some salt we're gonna make a
patty by pressing it into shape what's
basically happening is those breadcrumbs
are starting to absorb the rendered beef
fat well that happens it makes the
breadcrumbs really crispy and those
breadcrumbs are really going to
accentuate the fried crunchiness of this
burger
I believe that beef and breadcrumbs are
the original slug burger but today if
you ask for a slug burger in the south
you're actually not gonna get a beef
burger you're gonna get a pork burger
it's actually a burger made from ground
pork and soy flour look at that
oh my goodness
[Music]
also this burger has no cheese we're not
putting cheese on this burger you know
why because cheese didn't exists on
burgers when this burger was invented
this burger actually predates the
cheeseburger by probably two decades wow
it's so crunchy those crunchy bits have
absorbed that rendered beef fat and
almost made like it we have like a fry
and hamburger here I'm also gonna prep
the bun it's very important to the plate
oh [ __ ] so that coming just just pick up
here
sorry doping is slang from the burger
world which basically means that you're
preparing the bun a little bit of
mustard some pickles and that's it I'm
using a very uncomplicated white button
because that's honestly what would have
happened 100 years ago this burger goes
back to the dawn of the hamburger age oh
[ __ ] Oh mmm
oh really good that's what well should I
say to me that tastes unbelievably
accurate the value of appreciating a
regional burger like this is that you
get to go back in time and experience
what somebody may have experienced 100
years ago
it's about method it's about the method
of cooking and keeping things simple
keeping things stork ly accurate that's
my job my job is make sure you
appreciate the regional hamburger like
the slug burger
[Music]
Ruby okay I'm glad you miss flute class
you tell that teacher we're gonna play
extra flute today